we take greater pains to persuade others
that we are happy
and endeavoring to think so ourselves
a healthy man wants a thousand things
a sick man only wants one
if they spit at you behind your back
it means you're ahead of them
he who knows all the answers has not
been asked all the questions
the gem cannot be polished without
friction
nor man perfected without trials
the man who asks a question is a fool
for a minute
the man who does not ask
is a fool for life
if what one has to say is not better
than silence
then one should keep silent
study the past if you would define the
future
choose a job you love
and you will never have to work a day in
your life
[Music]
life is really simple
but we insist on making it complicated
give a bowl of rice to a man
and you will feed him for a day
teach him to grow his own rice
and you will save his life
it does not matter how slowly you go
as long as you do not stop
we have two lives
and the second begins when we realize we
only have one
tell me and i will forget
show me and i may remember
involve me
and i will understand
to know what you know
is what you do not know
that is true knowledge
[Music]
don't do unto others
what you don't want done unto you
if you are the smartest person in the
room
then you are in the wrong room
the man who says he can
and the man who says he cannot
are both correct
attack the evil that is within yourself
rather than attacking the evil that is
in others
he who flatters a man is his enemy
he who tells him of his faults
is his maker
the man who moves a mountain
begins by carrying away small stones
[Music]
i hear and i forget
i see and i remember
i do
and i understand
it is easy to hate
and it is difficult to love
this is how the whole scheme of things
works
all good things are difficult to achieve
and bad things are very easy to get
[Music]
the funniest people are the saddest ones
to see what is right to not do it is the
worst cowardice
your life is what your thoughts make it
it is obvious that the goals cannot be
reached
don't adjust the goals
adjust the action steps
by three methods we may learn wisdom
first
by reflection
which is noblest
second by imitation
which is easiest
and third by experience
which is the bitterest
before you embark on a journey of
revenge
dig two graves
it is more shameful to distrust our
friends than to be deceived by them
[Music]
forget injuries
never forget kindness
[Music]
the man who chases two rabbits
catches neither
learning without thought is labor lost
thought without learning
is perilous
if you make a mistake and do not correct
it
this is called a mistake
learn as if you were not reaching your
goal
and as though you were scared of missing
it
[Music]
if someone wants to offend you greatly
then it is even worse for him
our greatest glory is not in never
falling
but in rising every time we fall
the superior man is modest in his speech
but exceeds in his actions
roads were made for journeys
not destinations
think of tomorrow
the past can't be mended
worry not
that no one knows you
seek to be worth knowing
[Music]
you